deputy chairman fred hampton of the
illinois black panther party
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to your weekly ticket
first up fantastic beasts three we'll
see mads mikkelson replace
johnny depp as geralt grindelwald
mikkelsen will appear alongside jude law
as a young albus dumbledore as well as
eddie redmayne as maj's zoologist newt
scamander
and alison tsudal and katherine
waterston as sisters queenie and tina
goldstein
the film will be directed by david yates
who directed the first two movies as
well as the latter harry potter films
paramount pictures just released its
first look at its live-action adaptation
of clifford the big red dog
the film which is based on the beloved
children's books was first announced in
2012 and was at one point
scheduled for release on april 8 2016.
the 2021 film stars darby camp as emily
elizabeth a middle schooler who meets a
magical animal rescuer who gifts her
a little red puppy however she never
anticipated to wake up to find a giant
10-foot hound in her small new york city
apartment
the film also stars tony hale david
allen grier and russell wong
it was a couple years ago when tiffany
haddish was in talks to start in a new
21 jump street movie
taking over where channing tatum and
jonah hill left off in 22 jump street
however with the news of deadpool 3
hiring writers wendy molino and lizzie
mullen o lozlin we get a few
updates on the jump street universe and
alumni the phil lord and chris miller 21
and 22 jump street spin-off with a draft
written by the molino sisters will be
titled jump street
now for her pleasure and haddish is
still attached
and in separate news lord and miller are
set to reunite with their 21 jump street
star channing tatum
on an untitled comedy thriller inspired
by the universal monster movies
whichever film hits production first is
anyone's guess but both a jump street
spin-off and reunion are
in the works
as this year comes to a close and we
inch closer and closer to the 2021 award
season we're taking a look at some
awards contenders
and with this award season being one of
the longest yet considering the oscars
were pushed back to april 30th
2021 the movie year doesn't actually end
in 2020
instead the eligibility cutoff will now
be february 28
2021 and here to help us break it down
is rotten tomatoes awards specialist
jacqueline coley jacqueline can you like
walk us through what films we will be
seeing
a lot this award season and what is even
the state of the race right now
it's a very interesting race i will say
for most award strategists we've all
kind of had to write a
new playbook in the times of covid and
so
because it's a mostly digital season
meaning the only films that will be
eligible are the ones that came out in
that very small window
in between last year's oscars and before
we shut down
most of the titles are actually smaller
independent films that the studios felt
comfortable keeping on the schedule
due to the fact that theaters uh will be
shut down so you're saying things like
nomad land from chloe zhao things like
one night in miami
for regina king and the new film menari
that stars steve young and that's from
a24 the same folks that brought us
moonlight
a lot of indie stuff that should make it
really interesting a lot of new faces at
the uh at the award well
at the awards are there gonna be an
actual awards building
going on i do actually think we will
have an award ceremony for
folks that watch the in the emmys and
how they did that sort of digital
ceremony i would envision that that was
like the trial
run that the oscars are then going to
sort of implement you know
their hazmat suit people handing out
oscars
with the like sitting at home acceptance
speech
i think they're going to adopt a lot of
that also it's pushed back till
april so there is a chance that they
could have some kind of a larger
gathering
if this new news about the vaccine and
such uh continues to have promising
results it's still very much up in the
air
but i think there'll be a ceremony
needless to say
they could have it at the beach you know
it's like nice
hey the independent spirit awards are in
a hangar
in uh santa monica i think that's where
i got the idea yeah
just like put it out there put them
right next to each other all right but
what
movies have yet to be released do you
expect to
sh maybe like shift the race what's
really interesting is there aren't too
many films that folks know
nothing about yet to be released that we
think
can be contenders now there's films like
promising young woman
and stuff like uh from earlier this year
they had minari which now has a date but
not a lot of folks have actually
seen it but for the most part we kind of
know the players we gonna have mank
from netflix uh hillbilly elegy which
just recently premiered to
lackluster critical reviews still has
two very exceptional performances at the
center of it with amy adams
and glenn close so we kind of genuinely
know who the players are going
to be a few yet to be released our
midnight sky which is the george clooney
star and he also directs
and white tiger which stars priyanka
tropra which is actually
based off of a very best-selling crime
thriller that was sort of which was a
national book award winner from a few
years ago
the films that could shape the race that
we don't know yet to be released however
are actually three very interesting
titles the first of which
being french dispatch this is the new
wes anderson film that stars timothy
chalamet and sasha ronan
and then we also have a film that again
has not had a release date scheduled
that is judas and the black messiah
which a lot of folks are looking for
something for daniel kahlua
and maybe also lakeith stanfield but
other players like west side story
dune and all of these sort of like big
budget oscar contenders have all decided
they are vacating
and honestly at this point barring an
announcement in the next coming weeks
the films that have been announced are
going to be the ones that are contending
god that's that's crazy interesting to
see
even how things pan out this year and
like
like who shows up and whatnot but i'm
curious what is
your favorite from this year i have a
few favorites from this year
um the the film that is really sort of
in my heart at this current moment
for a host of reasons is ma rainey's
black bottom
now this is from august wilson the
african-american playwright who also
wrote fences and he's had
several hit broadway adaptations and
this
is his musical extravaganza and it stars
viola davis and the tragically great
late chadwick boseman
and it has the best performance i have
ever seen from him and that is saying a
lot considering
just the incredible things that he was
able to do in his short 43 years on this
earth
it would be a posthumous awards campaign
which is a delicate thing if folks
remember how they handled the heath
ledger
ward's campaign when he ended up winning
for the dark knight i would
expect similar things expect to see his
wife and his family as part of the
awards campaign
and being as this will be likely a love
letter to his
legacy a lot of award strategists and
pundits including myself
are pretty much saying it's his to lose
um
this is not just gonna be for what he
does in maharani's black bottom which is
incredible
but also just for his legacy as a
filmmaker
yeah that would be great that would be
great now we asked our viewers
on twitter who hasn't won an oscar that
absolutely
should have and i'm curious who do you
think should have won an oscar that
hasn't
this is like such a hard question as
someone that has literally
literally gotten upset and like didn't
feel like i could go to school the next
day
after certain things won oscars that i
didn't think should have
uh for the female side one that
definitely comes to mind
is angela bassett for what's love got to
do with it no shade to holly hunter but
she was a double nominee that year and
her better performance was in the firm
so that one really sticks with me for
classic film
fans i think tons of us are upset that
peter o'toole
star of lawrence of arabia and just like
a huge story career
also never sort of achieved an oscar but
the one that is in my heart and the one
that
absolutely should as soon as possible is
ethan hawk he's a texas boy
he has been nominated i believe now four
times and has been even
even more oscar nominated films where
they just didn't award his performance
including
uh his film from a few years ago forced
reform which it was a
travesty that he was not nominated for
that but i really
really truly want to see ethan hawk walk
home with the golden statuette he is my
leonardo dicaprio
i was thinking about the question myself
who who would be
for me and my brain wouldn't let me get
past
my beef that tony collette did not win
for hereditary
and so no matter if if or if she hasn't
won one
i'm angry about that and i still think
we could nominate her this year
for that crying scene alone i still
think about it and it
it haunts me so that's my answer she's
in the conversation
uh this year with the charlie kaufman
i'm thinking of ending things which just
picked up a few gotham awards so she's
not
out of the realm of possibility i mean
also too when you just think about it i
mean
this year if there was going to be a
horror performance like i don't know
maybe elizabeth moss an invisible man
or maybe the folks from his house
there's a lot of
really exceptional horror performances
this year that
could break through to maybe get some
oscar love or at least be part of the
conversation so
the horror bias that the academy has i'm
really hoping that both with that
female filmmakers and marginalized
filmmakers this sort of like
netflix or streaming season allows those
folks to sort of take center stage
yeah let's let's get scared academy and
let's let's get scared let's get some
spooky stuff in there you know
i mean the one of the most winning films
ever was a horror film silence of the
lamb sweeping all the top awards
still in the books there you go all
right jacqueline thank you so much for
joining us and for you at home
who do you think deserves an oscar that
didn't win one yet leave us a comment
below and let us know
jacqueline where can people find you
well of course you can always read
whatever i'm writing on
rottentomatoes.com be sure to check out
our awards tour hub where we have
all of the latest news nominations
winners and my trophy talk column where
i break down
all of the insider scoops on who is in
contention and who
is not and of course if folks just want
to chat with me or see pictures of my
dog you can find me on
any social media platform under that
jaclyn because i'm that girl that talks
movies
what kind of dog do you have i have a
very cute maltese poodle who is
begging for attention as we speak i'm
going to give it to
him before he starts barking in this
video okay you go
we're going to talk about what movies
are coming out all right
all right see you later bye
available to watch in theaters no mad
land
[Music]
hey linda come over and join us now i'm
just gonna take a little walk
be back soon
following the economic collapse of a
company town in rural nevada
fern played by frances mcdormand packs
her van and sets off on a road exploring
a life outside of conventional society
as a modern day
nomad the third feature film from
director chloe zao nomad land features
real nomads linda mae
swanky and bob wells as fern's mentors
and comrades
in her exploration through the vast
landscape of the american west
[Music]
and available to watch at home on
thursday ammonite
it pleases me you struck up a friendship
together
what is it something nothing
in 1800s england acclaimed but
unrecognized fossil hunter mary ening
played by kate winslet
works alone on the rugged southern
coastline with the days of her famed
discoveries behind her she now searches
for common fossils to sell to tourists
to support herself and her ailing mother
when a wealthy visitor entrusts marry
with the care of his wife charlotte
played by sercia ronan
she cannot afford to turn the offer down
mary initially clashes with her
unwelcome guest
but despite the distance between their
social classes and personalities
an intense bond begins to develop
between the two women
alright well that's it for today but
leave us a comment and let us know what
your award season's predictions are
i'm kale and i'll see you next time
you